fuego un aeropuerto tomado por
manifestantes en Almaty la ciudad más
grande del país y el internet cortado
Kazajistán vive las mayores protestas
desde 2011 estás comenzaron por el alza
de los precios en el gas licuado que se
han duplicado en un año el Estado tenía
el control pero la escasez obligo a
liberalizar provocando un aumento del
precio los kazajos utilizan
habitualmente el gas para desplazarse en
sus automóviles la subida sumada una
infracción en torno al 9 % y el
consecuente aumento en los precios de la
canasta han desatado protestas de una
nueva generación
Kazajistán es el mayor de los cinco
países ex soviéticos de Asia Central y
ha destacado por su estabilidad por lo
que su riqueza en metales y petróleo ha
traído a inversionistas internacionales
especialmente chinos y rusos
alianzas que han dicho que el presidente
tokayev acusa a los manifestantes de
terroristas extranjeros y haya pedido
ayuda el bloque de seguridad liderado
por Rusia alianza que ya acordó enviar
un contingente de paz a Kazajistán
geopolítica la que también se le suman
problemas internos otra de las medidas
de tokayev ha sido destituir al
expresidente Nazarbayev de 31 años como
líder del Consejo de Seguridad este fue
presidente entre 1991 y 2019 pero su
sombra continúa presente en la toma de
decisiones como líder de la nación y en
el culto a su figura como demuestra
cuando en 2019 la capital paso a
llamarse Nursultan su nombre abusos
políticos que sumados el aumento de la
pobreza han generado que los jóvenes
salgan al grito de que se vaya de una
vez por todas
[Aplausos]